- WHAT UP, VEGAS?
YO!
- WHAT'S UP?
- THREE DAYS...
ME AND YOU, FREE DRINKS,
NAKED BIOTCHES.
- THIS IS GONNA BE
OUR [bleep] RIGHT HERE, DOG.
THIS IS GONNA BE MY--
LET'S GET SOME JAMS
GOING UP IN THIS BITCH
RIGHT NOW!
- YEAH.
- NUMBER ONE THREE WEEKS
RUNNING,
IT'S ROLL WITH ME.
- OH, [bleep]!
THAT'S MY JAM RIGHT THERE.
I LOVE THIS SONG.
- I LOVE THIS SONG TOO, MAN.
EVERYBODY LOVES THIS SONG.
- WHAT, UH-HUH.
[woman vocalizing]
WHAT?
both: ♪ ROLL WITH ME,
ROLL WITH ME ♪
♪ LIGHT THE NIGHT ON FIRE
WITH ME ♪
- ♪ GIRL, YOU KNOW THAT I GOT
WHAT YOU NEED, SEE ♪
♪ DON'T GET GREEDY ♪
- [mumbling]
- ♪ GIVE IT UP SWEETLY ♪
♪ LET ME SET THAT BODY FREE ♪
♪ 'CAUSE WHAT YOU GOT,
YOU GOT TO GIVE IT TO ME ♪
♪ WHAT? ♪
- ♪ WHAT? ♪
- ♪ LIGHT THE NIGHT ON FIRE
WITH ME ♪
- ♪ EVER SINCE
I WAS ROCKING A ONESIE ♪
♪ I KNOW THAT YOU WAS ♪
both:
♪ SECOND TO NONE, B ♪
- [mumbling]
- ♪ GROWING UP ♪
♪ AND LEARNING ABCs
AND 1, 2, 3s ♪
♪ HOPING YOU'D LEARN WE ♪
♪ WERE MEANT TO BE ♪
♪ EVEN WAY BACK THEN ♪
♪ EVERY LITTLE [bleep]'S
NOT A PERFECT TEN ♪
♪ BUT THEN YOU KNOW,
I GROW UP ♪
♪ AND GOT A LITTLE BIT OLDER,
A LITTLE BIT BOLDER ♪
♪ BRUSHING OFF MY SHOULDERS,
ALMOST A MAN ♪
♪ THOSE PLAYGROUND FEELINGS
GREW STRONGER ♪
- [mumbling]
- ♪ COULDN'T WAIT MUCH LONGER ♪
♪ NOW WITH ME ♪
- ♪ ROLL-- ♪
- ♪ YOU BELONG, GIRL ♪
both: ♪ ROLL WITH ME,
ROLL WITH ME ♪
♪ LIGHT THE NIGHT ON FIRE
WITH ME ♪
- ♪ HERE'S YOUR VERSE,
TAKE IT RIGHT NOW ♪
- [mumbling]
- ♪ PRESENTATE ♪
♪ AND I AIN'T PLAYING ♪
♪ ON TOP OF THE GAME
AND THE LIFE I BE PLAYIN' ♪
♪ LISTEN CLOSE
TO THE [bleep] I BE SAYIN' ♪
[music stops]
- NO, WHAT THE HELL?
DON'T TURN IT OFF
JUST 'CAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW IT.
- WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
WHEN WE GET TO VEGAS?
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
DON'T CHANGE THE SUBJECT
ABOUT WHAT WE GONNA DO IN VEGAS.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE WORDS,
JUST ADMIT
YOU DON'T KNOW THE WORDS.
- I KNOW THE WORDS.
I TOLD YOU.
WHY WOULD I MAKE UP
THAT I KNOW--DON'T KNOW--
THAT'S RIDICULOUS, MAN.
NO, I KNOW THE WORDS.
- IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU DIDN'T KNOW THE WORDS.
- I KNOW THE WOR--HEY, LIST--
HEY, LISTEN TO ME, MAN.
- WHAT? WHAT?
- I KNOW THE WORDS TO THAT SONG.
- OKAY. OKAY.
- EVERYBODY KNOWS.
- NO, NO, IT'S NOT OKAY, 'CAUSE
YOU OBVIOUSLY DON'T BELIEVE ME.
HEY, DUDE,
ON OUR FRIENDSHIP...
I KNOW THE WORDS
TO ROLL WITH ME.
- OKAY.
I'M SORRY.
- IT'S ALL RIGHT.
- JUST LET IT GO.
I'M SORRY.
THAT WAS STUPID.
STUPID.
- I'LL TURN IT BACK UP.
- HA, HA, YO!
I LOVE THAT TRACK SO MUCH.
I'M SORRY, I GOT TO PLAY IT
AGAIN. THIS IS ROLL WITH ME.
101.3 K-BEAT.
- ♪ ROLL WITH ME,
ROLL WITH ME ♪
- ♪ LIGHT THE NIGHT ON FIRE
WITH ME ♪
- [grunts, sniffs]
YEAH, THAT REALLY HURT.